Irena Sendler was a Polish, Catholic nurse who worked in Warsaw...
...during the Nazi occupation of Poland...
...and saved 2,500 Jewish children from certain death.
During that time, she worked for the Warsaw social services.
After the creation of the Warsaw ghetto,...
...Irena Sendler was able to save many children...
...by smuggling them out of the ghetto to save them from being deported...
...to the concentration camps.
She transported the children in ambulances as if they were sick from typhus,...
...hid them in the trash cans, tool chests, supply boxes or coffins,...
...and later put them in convents and Polish Catholic families.
She created an archive with the real identities of the children...
...so one day they could be reunited with their family members.
She wrote on a strip of paper the Jewish names of the children...
...with the new Polish name and addresses where they were taken.
All of them she put in a jar, which she buried by a tree in her garden.
In 1943, she was detained by the Gestapo...
...and taken to prison where she was brutally tortured.
She never betrayed her mission and she was sentenced to death...
...but a soldier freed her, thanks to the intervention from the Polish resistance.
At the end of the war, she was able to recover her archives...
...although most of the families of children she saved had died in concentration camps.
In 1965, the organization Yad Vashem in Jerusalem...
...granted her the title "Righteous Among the Nations".
During the last year of her life, she received thanks from many children she had saved...
...and was nominated for the Nobel Peace Prize.